though which is directed by Robert
Eggers and stars anya taylor joy i
believe has hit her name correctly as a
young girl who lives in 1630s new
england on a small farm with her family
there just might be a witch that lives
out in the woods causing some serious
problems for this family i was really
excited to see this movie because i've
heard so much about it lots of buzz i
love horror films i love a good horror
film and walking out of this theater man
was I pumped because I saw a great one
one of the things I love so much about
this movie is that it's not just about a
witch it's not just horror conventions
and cliches and tropes that we're used
to seeing just because they can do some
scary stuff with some music or some jump
scares it's really about how a terrible
situation brought on by a supernatural
entity Effects of family this movie is
more so about this family tearing
themselves apart when one family member
gets snatched away by said which they
don't know if there's something in the
woods they're unsure of what's going on
and they all start to suspect one
another they're stuck on this small
little farm and it becomes very
suspenseful and very tragically dramatic
because you see this entire family's
foundation erode because of this witch
but none of them really know what's
actually going on and that's why this
film was so great it wasn't just about
something scary it was about how that
scary thing can have an effect on a
family and so it felt more realistic and
grounded you could actually relate to
these characters and the acting was
terrific particularly the daughter and
the father these are two really good
performances the young boy the family
was a little hot and cold for me he came
in he had some really good lines and
then he had some really terrible lines
as well and then there's one scene where
he just blew me away that scared the
crap out of me I won't spoil it for you
I was just sitting there like okay so
it's a good scene this movie also
features a haunting score that really
emphasizes how important a great score
is for a horror film it builds certain
scenes up so much and it really makes
you feel the true horror of the
horrifying situation there's also very
tense editing long
takes slow moving slider shots things
that can really creep up on you and get
you into the film and a style that
really makes you appreciate the location
and that's one of the things I loved
about the which you feel this
environment it's a very claustrophobic
movie also what's great is a depiction
of the witch the way it's used I won't
get into it because you just have to
experience it but the way they set up
this character and the way she was able
to do certain things was really great I
was enthralled by that aspect of the
movie it really really got under my skin
in the best type of way as for issues
the first act is a little slow there is
about 20 minutes where you're like where
is this movie going and once you realize
that it's really more about the family
it starts to make more sense because for
about 20 minutes there you're like let's
let's get going here let's go the first
like 10 minutes we're amazing there's
some incredible cinematography but then
it gets a little bit slow for a minute
but once the second act starts and into
that third act and especially the ending
this movie was brilliant I loved all of
that some aspects of the way this film
was directed and the cinematography did
remind me of the village it looks really
great but I do wish the colors were a
little more vibrant it can be very dull
looking and very great but that isn't a
way reflecting the depression that's
going through this family and the
terrible situation they're in possibly
I'm just kind of assuming what the
director may have been going for but it
did look a little bit dour to me and I
wish the colors were a little bit more
vibrant but that's kind of a nitpick I
guess it's not really that much of a
criticism the which is a terrifically
suspenseful film with a very good story
and excellent acting and an amazing
ending beautiful score I mean this is a
really good horror film I'm going to
give the witch an A - I hope it's
opening near you if it is check it out
it is worth your time some people may
hate this film it's unconventionally
edited and directed and it's almost
perversely designed to make you feel
uneasy which worked for me but some
audiences who just want your typical
horror film may hate that guy thank you
so much as always for watching I greatly
greatly appreciate it and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
steppen eyes